hey what up this is John Delaney with
Ramsey Network
I'm with the past year in my
neighborhood and we were modeling what
listening looks like what submission I'm
being quiet looks like so dr. John Fagan
and brilliant kind lots of experience
and you're a generous and so I
appreciate your time you spent with me
you're very kind
so we've talked about my neighborhood
and the sidewalks my kids run up and
down on alright and the and the way my
neighborhood shaped and shifted and
moved that led to some of the things
we've seen the last couple weeks yeah
we've talked about you as a dad what
your parents did to make sure they
nurtured your heart growing up and the
things you and your wife were doing for
your kids so now I want to pivot a
little bit and I want to be the
universal white guy right so for those
of you who are teachers or professors
it's common that there may be one Latino
guy in the classroom and the professor
will say things like hey yo what a
Mexican kids think about right that's
just kind of a normal thing that
underrepresented groups experience all
the time so in this moment I want to
flip that script and say on behalf of
all white people I want to ask dr. John
I want to ask you a couple of questions
that are just floating out there in
space let's do it
okay and I only want you to speak on
behalf of your experiences and your
heart that's all the hair cool cool so
number one I keep hearing everything
about systemic racism it's the system
man right I grew up on Rage Against the
Machine
I've heard about system for 20 years
yeah what are what does that mean what
are you talking about when you talk
about systemic racism or systemic
oppression another way to use it
determine is structural racism to that
there are baked within systems already
established outcomes
okay alright so you're telling me that
before the game even gets played we
already know who going already done okay
rigged okay I like that we're rigged
okay job from the job
African Americans arrived in this
country at 1690 okay
emancipation proclaimation freed slaves
in 1863 most folk got it around 1865 you
know the Galveston story
I know ghost yeah so so 1865 all slaves
are free okay but they start with
nothing they have built a country that
they do not own anything in right and
slavery in legislation or or freedom in
legislation does not mean de-facto
freedom okay right so you're dealing
with folks who are free but who have
nothing who have to start over and then
there is a group of folks who don't want
those slaves freed in fact they fought a
war to make sure they they would be free
so you've got folks now who are free
trying to figure out what the American
experiment means for them okay but they
are still under the systems that were
operating in slavery so does this
analogy work the game of life is a mile
and people who look like me the gun went
off we have to take off and we are 800
meters we're half way down on this mile
and then they turn to folks who look
like you and say ready go
and I may be running saying hey we were
all running the same race everybody
you're free to run to but I had an 800
meter head start you don't just have an
800 meter head start you don't have any
hurdles ah you don't have any puddles
rocks anymore anymore yeah you don't you
don't have you don't have weights on
your ankles or traumatic baggage on my
backside absolutely okay so so when I
say systemic that's what we're talking
about we talk about structure
a structural the way the system is set
up okay
we're designed not to succeed I'll give
an example
yep ending a picture of a baked in
absolutely in America the number one
means of wealth accumulation it's home
ownership okay that's document yep home
ownership is how you get started
particularly in African Americans in
African American communities it's the
number one way to build wealth and
transfer wealth right and the transfer
well okay then tell me why in America
white Americans white families are 20
times wealthier than black families hmm
I'll tell you why because things like in
1933 when the Fair Housing
Administration was founded by Hoover
even VA loans from persons who were
coming back from World War one being
able to apply for loans African
Americans were restricted African
Americans didn't have the opportunities
to apply for loan or to even qualify and
if they did apply they were rejected
then when they tried to build homes
there were restrictive covenants put in
place in particular communities where
black folks could not live hmm let's
talk about redlining for a bullet okay
where if I'm coming to appraise the
value of a home or value of an area
where black people live the property
values are low price has a value honey
daddy rating in a C rating in white
areas you get an A or B rating in fact
if black folks moved into white areas
the ratings went down so what you're
saying is same block same bricks same
builders same pool in the backyard yes
on this side of the street because of
the color of the skin of the people
living in those bricks same bricks the
rating gets better yes the house value
could go up yes so that when my parents
are 80 and they move to their retirement
home and that house transfers to me and
my sister yes we sell it and it's
tripled in value yes we take that money
buy our own houses
yes we use that money put down payments
on our bigger houses yes and so it goes
yeah and then across the street because
people who look more like you live in
these same bricks same houses they get a
lower rating yes so the lone values for
these appraisals can only cap it this
much yes and so it goes yes
then add in just what we would call
social determinants mm-hmm high
unemployment no access to health care
mass incarceration mm-hmm these elements
begin to set the storm set the perfect
storm for these distances to increase
not decrease let's talk about pandemic
with that a little bit more danger in
jabal kind of terrific you're talking
about this pandemic we're talking about
coronavirus right right it's not by
accident it's not coincidence that
african-americans make up 13% of the US
population but we make up 30% of Cova 19
deaths why is that it's because what we
call social determinants of health
because the way I've heard it painted
mmm by the universal white community
again I'm making this up don't get don't
leave me in comments is because people
in the black community aren't as hearing
to social distancing as well as they
should be that's cute that's right
that's very nice it's answer and it's a
it's a very liberating perspective for
the person who looks at it and wants to
not see systemic stuff okay what the
systemic reality is this public health
folks will tell you this that there are
social determinants of health that
exacerbate the disproportionate impact
on African American so it's not just
that we're not adhering to social
distance
what does heartaches here to social
distancing if you live in public housing
hmm and you got four people living in
five hundred square foot space hmm how
do you social distance if I don't have
access to food in my neighborhood food
deserts mm-hmm I don't have access to
healthy food then my body is already
under prepared to fight off
issues hmm furthermore I can't afford
PPE
protective measures and protective
equipment masks and those things we do a
food pantry at our church every week to
address food and security in our
neighborhood and folks come over in
public housing they don't have masks
because that's not the priority right
now the priority right now is eating
eating right right the homelessness
population predominately African
American mass incarceration
predominantly african-american and and
Latino well how do you quarantine in
prison hmm can't so it becomes an
incubating in incubation spot so Public
Health folk will tell you we say it this
way when America gets a cold black
America catches do more you okay because
whatever happens to America
there is a disproportionate impact
because of conditions and the system's
already set to turn it up
so is that up the volume in those
communities as a guy who studies mental
health one of the things we've talked
about in the pandemic is the higher your
stress level goes the more overactive
your immune response becomes the sicker
you the the better chance you have to
get sick sure and so what you're putting
out there is if you live a baseline of
I'm hungry or a baseline of I'm working
three jobs and this is the best Ike
that I'm captain response is going to
make you more susceptible to getting
sick absolutely
we also constitute mostly this most of
these Center workers right so there's
the high level of exposure because we're
on the frontlines we're the roomba
drivers we're the delivery folks we're
working in the grocery stores we have
the the lowest pay but the highest
service in jobs and so you're not gonna
pay me an affordable wage to make it but
you expect me to show up so that you
have what you need in a pandemic so we
can make sure there are food to be on
the whole food trucks that are getting
shipped out by Amazon right but I'm the
one who has to be
and then I don't have the option of not
loading because I got to eat my family
ID right all right huh so do you see the
systems right that kind of inter
intersecting and create this this this
isn't this is important because faith
communities faith communities we love to
do what I call charity okay
charity is responding to a need well
charity and charities great Jesus says
the poor you'll always have with you
right you have to respond to needs but
there's another step beyond charity
charity we have to do but the step
beyond charity is justice justice is not
a political term is a biblical term hmm
it was a Christian term it's it's found
the Old Testament and the New Testament
Jesus talks about it prophets talked
about it it's it's a sign of them like
dropping by the way go ahead it's it's
everywhere that's not the Luther but no
that's that's a theological in biblical
term so charity says person is hungry we
are for you justice says why is the same
person always hungry how far up the
river can we kill charity says we got a
man we've really got a minister to those
who are in prison Justice says why does
everybody in prison look the same color
hmm okay mo rule they call that as you
can see yeah like how do we get to that
place right so so so going up digging a
little bit deeper to find out that there
yeah there's just something baked in
here mm-hmm that makes it that okay so
Universal white question number two
don't all lives matter why why do you
get a black prom and I don't get a white
prom why do you why don't we get white
lives matter why do you get a special
life that matters mmm very question when
we say black lives matter it is not a
statement that all lives don't matter
mm-hmm it is a statement that black
lives have to be given attention to
because they are the ones under attack
so when I hear all lives matter what I
hear is this what about
ISM the persons are not willing to as
you've modeled and spoken up today
listen and sit with and explore the
experience and the exposure of persons
who have been marginalized black lives
matter is not an assertion that no other
life matters it means that this life
matters too but it's been ignored here's
my example when I was in when I was in
elementary school probably bout third
grade we were all sitting and reading
and our teacher was reading to us we
just finished snacking no no a few
moments ago
Cawood said it they said to me maybe
first grade maybe nicely met their love
snack snack it it was snack it we have a
break and then we come to sit on the on
the on the mat sit on the carpet and the
teachers gonna read to us while we're
reading man one of the kids
well my classmate starts choking he
didn't chew well his grapes and and one
is large lodged in his throat she stops
reading she drops the book runs over and
performed the Heimlich on that kid saved
that save that kid's life did all the
kids not matter in that moment mmm no
all the kids matter all the kids were
important but at that moment there was
one who was choking yeah and so that kid
demanded and needed the attention of the
authority in the room right now case
didn't say well she didn't come check on
me I wouldn't choke it okay teacher my
life for the right one in distress is
the one that gets the attention when a
when when there is a fire in the
neighborhood fire trucks don't show up
and spray water on every house hmm
they spray water on the house that's on
fire hmm it doesn't mean that the other
houses don't matter right it just means
that this moment they're not in danger
of death there's clearest in most lucid
explanation that I've ever heard I'm
grateful for the hope it makes a why do
i as the universal white community
automatically hear that as an indictment
why do I hear that as an exclusion term
instead of
a hand raised intern because of
something called privilege okay
privilege is this space that I live in
where I have always been the majority
okay and I've always been given the
attention and I'm always the one
listened to and I'm always the one given
opportunities I'm always the one given
exposure and I'm always the one provided
for care for and taken care of well when
I live in a place of privilege equality
feels like a pressure hmm but I operate
from privilege always having the
attention always having the resources
always being the voice I get to make the
boundaries I can make the cell the
boundaries I can set the rules you can
get intoxicated in that space right if
you never frequent other spaces where
you're not the privileged okay not the
majority so then when a situation occurs
where someone else gets equal or even
closely commensurate attention that you
were used to receiving it feels like
you're being oppressed but it's really
equality happening so equality feels
like oppression when I function and
operate in privilege so if I go back to
your elementary school classroom this is
common if you hang out with little kids
when little Billy's getting the Heimlich
maneuver mm-hmm and they call in the
teacher's aide and they call them the
nurse and all three of those teachers
kneeled down to make sure Billy's okay
it is absolutely to be expected that the
other first graders real quick are gonna
start getting itchy yeah start causing a
little bit of us because they want that
spotlight back some will even say I'm
coughing - someone will start chunking
imaginatively my daughter will do that
she'll go on say hey my stomach hurts
since you're here come check me okay
okay trying to get the attention back
okay because when I when I live in a
place of privilege where I'm always the
one that sets the conditions when I have
to share that space if I'm not used to
sharing that space it feels like I'm
oppressed
I was like the tenth time on my own show
I have anything had to say after that
below it
number three universal white question
number three what do I do now
neighborhood friend of mine who works
like three streets over four where I
rent my house yeah what do I do now hmm
I've heard that question quite a bit
imagine every white friend you have is
calling you emailing what do I do
and and and I know where that comes from
it comes from a place of feeling a bit
guilty in this moment and trying to do
something
our caution doing before you sit with
and wrestle with there's something to be
said about being contemplative and
thoughtful and observational in this
moment what can I do
that's exhausted that's an exhausting
question for folks who look like me
right now because I'm asking you to
solve my problem because everybody's
asking me to decipher interpret and
translate right now here here's what
would be a much more desired response
not what can I do buddy hey John here's
what I'm doing here's the approach I've
taken help me to see if this is help me
to see if this translates into something
that'll be effective and now not only am
I not the one who has to answer and
solve the problems you've owned that in
your space you've got influence you've
got agency and that there's something
you can do not man what do I do but
here's what I've decided to do I'm going
to I'm a marching the protest and I'm
gonna take some with my friends
now we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
show up and not lead it but follow black
leadership and the
moment and listen and respond and be
present and and use our privilege as a
space and an opportunity to help move
this movement forward those
conversations have been very fruitful
those interactions have been very
fruitful and affirming in this moment
yeah because they really show us that
there's that there's hope that that
folks really that there are really folks
who want to who want to get engaged who
see the issue may not know how but are
willing to put themselves on the line to
do it as a black man as a black person I
am NOT responsible for your education
hmm I'm not I'm not going to own that
you have to own that I got bootless that
I can give to you to help you start but
I don't have two and a half hours every
day to help walk my white friends
through what's going on there books out
there history tells the story don't
don't don't don't ask me what can you do
show me what you are doing what do you
tell the universal white person who is
now so nervous to say the wrong thing to
do the wrong thing I saw the last week
kind of a a outpouring you're not
talking off camera I have never seen a
collection of white people so invested
in learning more I've never received as
many calls as I have for books maybe the
protects I'm liking like I've never
received that hey can you like my wife
was looking for some books on the shelf
this morning and she's like where it's
like I'm just gave them all out they're
all out what do I tell I saw it an
influx of things on social media which
was met with almost an equal fervor of
you didn't say this right you should
have posted it this way you posted it on
the wrong day what you're just doing
this so you can get attention and follow
it like we're just doing this weird
imaginary ecosystem has taken on its own
things sure and so what do I tell
someone who looks like me who's saying I
won't sit this out
I'm gonna not do anything cuz I don't do
something wrong I don't want to say the
wrong thing I don't act in the wrong way
because I can't afford I can't afford
the misstep
well for me that is an indication that
you've not created and cultivated
relationships with people different from
you already because if if if I'm in a
space where I'm already in a
relationship and connection with folks
who are different from me then we've
already had some of these conversations
for years of what of what to do what not
to do or if we haven't had the
conversations I have the relational
capital to be able to have an honest
conversation and get guidance about how
to do it or I just sit back and pay
attention and and see you know what my
black friend I should have black friends
I should have brown friends I said
people don't look like me in that space
so I can sit down and get and learn from
them and figure out man how do I stand
and one of the ways to stand is just
solidarity you don't you don't
necessarily have to be right all the
time to be present mm-hmm right I don't
I don't have to necessarily say
something in order to be in solidarity
and being support as a pastor you I know
you go just as a nature of the job you
go to hospitals you sit with people when
their grandparents have died or when
their young child lost their life
forever yeah it's been my experience in
those moments that often saying nothing
and just presence I'm just gonna sit
here with you is the most part that's
the most that's Jesus at the well right
he'd say a lot he just showed up it
changes the game it changes the game but
I also know it takes some time to get
there because there we live in a culture
of doing just talking and doing and
solving yeah we learn the culture of
doing we got to do and if I don't do
something if I don't produce something
my value is determined by what I do and
produce my valerie's not determined by
who I am I don't have anymore
microphones to drop but that's yes so so
that culture creates this angst like we
we don't like silence we don't like
simple space of presence of being
with that you know if I don't do that
I'm not effective in this moment
presence means that means means
everything there were folks there folks
are showing up the protests who live in
suburbs who don't live in the urban
areas there they're white right but they
what they understand they're privileged
and um you're seeing the videos and of
this stuff that one other things the
beauty of this moment is that the
revolution is social media is it's
televised right we're we're seeing the
the stories and anecdotes of how folks
with privilege are engaging and enabling
folks without privilege I've seen I've
seen white protesters white participants
in marches show up and wrap themselves
around black protestors because they
recognize already that the police
responds differently to a white body
then they do a black body and so in
essence they put themselves as a barrier
to protect those black bodies that may
not be protected otherwise and that's an
example right in other spaces it's just
walking with it's standing by and
protests I've been to protests I've been
a part of its multi-ethnic and it's it's
incredible it's a sea of multi-ethnic
humanity that is standing with not
standing not standing with not speaking
for standing with being present being
active allowing their faces to be seen
knowing that there might be some
consequences to their face being seen in
this space and and they don't care hmm
that's powerful presence hmm man I could
talk to you all day man it's been it's
been uh it's been rich I won't say it's
been fun no no no and I want to never
want to know you're exhausted I know you
got you gave up time that the only thing
on earth that some zero is time you
don't get back and this this time we've
had these last few videos have been at
the expense of your wife and your kids
and your church and so I'm grateful for
you thank you you know I'm I'm I'm
grateful to be here to have this
conversation and to be in a space where
we can we can just be honest right I
think this models may be for folks are
watching believe in models for me the
space is how we handle and manage the
privilege we've been given hmm
in in in America you would be
interpreted or translated as having
privilege mm-hmm but there are spaces
that I go into well I'm giving
privileges hmm well I'm the privileged
one I'm the one paid attention to mmm
and the same modeling that you have
given today is the same modeling I have
to give it's the same kind of spaced
privilege privilege is portable man it
really is determined by the cultural
ecosystem you walk into yeah your
privilege as a white man I'm privileged
as a black man in spaces where black
women are not valued mmm right so so as
you have elevated a voice that perhaps
folks may not hear if you had not given
that platform I got to do the same thing
hmm
thank you for modeling that first well
thank you for honoring me with the
conversation I I'm gonna strongly
recommend challenge whatever you want to
say go back and watch all three of these
videos and then watch them again and
then watch them again and I hope they're
uncomfortable I hope they challenge you
to be quiet
I hope they challenge you to listen and
I hope that overall whether this is with
your partner with your kids with your
coworkers
if somebody says something you see
something you experience something and
your first thought is no way why is that
let that be the moment you'd be quiet
and you lean in and learn more and seek
to understand somebody else is hard not
to impose your rightness not to impose
your facts not to oppose your intellect
just listen and be with be with your a
gift appreciate you man I hope this
isn't the last time you and I hang out
absolutely Matt I'm not gonna record any
more of these will record smoke its dr.
John Maloney with Ramsey Network thank
you for joining us and we'll talk to you
soon